[Musique]
kakistocratie
kakistochats mais quel mot bizarre
que peut-il désigner une maladie
psychique une démonstration mathématique
une contrée bizarre
l'élevage des kakis rien de tout cela
la kakistocratie comme beaucoup de mots
savants et forgés sur deux mots grecs
kakistos les pires Kratos le
gouvernement
la kakistocratie c'est le gouvernement
par les pires
le règne des médiums
le pouvoir des incompétents
alors ça pourrait être le titre d'un
thriller ou d'une sombre fiction
et en fait c'est une situation que vous
rencontrez peut-être tous les jours
vous êtes vous posez la question
récemment
comment mon manager
on bosse on PDG
est-il arrivé à ce poste alors qu'il est
complètement incompétent
ou autre formule comment se PDG se bosse
est-il encore en poste après des années
alors qu'il est nul et que tout le monde
le sait
bienvenue en kakistocratie
alors quand j'ai commencé à évoquer ce
concept
sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai eu des
centaines de messages et ça continue
alors il y a des gens qui me remercient
d'avoir posé un mot même compliqué sur
une situation complexe qu'il vivait
qu'il n'arrivait pas à décrypter
et puis il y avait aussi il y a toujours
des centaines de messages de gens qui
m'exprimaient leur souffrance
car ce n'est pas simple de travailler en
kakistocratie
vous découvrez quoi que l'incompétence
que la médiocrité ont de la valeur
alors que depuis tout petit ou vous dit
quoi faut bien travailler à l'école pour
avoir un diplôme il faut être compétent
pour être recruté il faut être le
meilleur pour être promu en
kakistocratie
tout fait toutes ces valeurs qui
forgaient votre existence mérite
reconnaissance compétences explose
disparaissent
il y a de quoi être perturbé
et puis au quotidien ce n'est pas simple
d'avoir un manager incompétent
il faut faire à sa place
il faut aussi gérer un sentiment de
frustration et d'injustice car on a
travaillé dur nous pour en arriver là
on peut aussi ressentir de la honte pour
son organisation
et ça peut aller jusqu'à la perte
d'estime de soi
donc c'est bien de poser un mot sur un
phénomène mais ça ne suffit pas il faut
comprendre le pourquoi et le comment de
la kakistocratie
ça vous intéresse
alors je vais vous livrer deux niveaux
d'explication là au niveau plus des
individus et l'autre plus au niveau des
systèmes car il y a des systèmes
organisés de kakistocratie
au niveau des individus il y a trois
comportements qu'on rencontre
classiquement vous les connaissez le
premier rejoint ce qu'on appelle le
principe de Peter
que plus on monte dans la hiérarchie
plus on rencontre son incompétence au
début on est très compétent puis moins
compétent puis de moins en moins et dans
tous ces dispositifs de promotion à
l'ancienneté si on ne sait pas dire non
et bien on se retrouve en situation de
pouvoir incompétent pour sa fonction
deuxième situation c'est ce qu'on peut
appeler le piège de la compétence
vous êtes chef de service
et vous savez dans votre équipe
quelqu'un d'hyper compétent un expert ou
une experte
qui crache à lui ou elle voilà la
boutique tourne tout marche les autres
c'est moins bien qu'est-ce que vous
faites et bien vous cherchez à le garder
vous allez éviter de le perdre parce que
ça serait trop long trop compliqué et au
contraire vous allez plutôt sur noter
faire partir les moins compétents qui
vont aller tranquillement vers des
promotions
troisième comportement kakistocrate
c'est tout simplement la peur de la
compétence
vous n'êtes pas très compétent on vous
demande de recruter des talents super
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
ben vous mettre devant votre
incompétence et pire de prendre votre
place
donc il vaut peut-être mieux recruter
des moins compétents pour continuer à
les dominer et à briller
je passe au système donc le système il y
a trois grands leviers de la
kakistocratie
le premier c'est la dette
alors j'ai dure
vous recrutez un compétent ou une
compétence
normale il vous doit rien au contraire
il va contribuer à l'organisation à
l'entreprise et vous recrutez quelqu'un
qui n'est pas assez compétent pour le
poste
et bien il vous doit quelque chose il
vous est redevable et il le sera toute
sa carrière c'est comme ça que se
construisent par exemple les mandarines
universitaires
notre levier
des systèmes kakistocrates c'est la
configuration clinique
vous connaissez aussi
ces entreprises ou ce qui est plus
important c'est d'embaucher son frère sa
soeur son oncle son cousin
qui allait au syndrome du fils du patron
parce que le clan il se moque de la
compétence et de la performance son seul
objectif c'est de se perpétuer
ensuite la mafia comme illustration
et puis le dernier mécanisme et bien
c'est le système la négation de la
personne au profit du système
je me moque que tu sois compétent ou
incompétente c'est moi qui décide qui
sera probu qui ne le sera pas on
retrouve ses configurations dans des
systèmes totalitaires ou des partis
politiques régissent la vie des gens
alors après tout s'entrecroisent et
s'entremêle il y a des gens qui ont des
comportements qui stoppent puis d'autres
qui sont dans des systèmes
mais au centre on voit bien que la
question qui se pose c'est la loyauté
posez-vous la question est-ce que vous
êtes loyal à vous et à votre carrière ou
est-ce que vous êtes loyal ou bien
commun qui est une entreprise une
association une administration
la promotion pour bons et loyaux
services
service acquis à quoi
mais on sent bien que la kakistocratie
c'est l'antithèse du management qui par
définition aide les gens à se développer
à s'épanouir agrandir en compétences
alors comment chacun a son niveau au
vôtre peut-il avancer sur ce sujet
je vous propose quatre étapes la
première c'est de faire un diagnostic
est-ce que réfléchissez vous avez dans
votre entourage professionnel repéré ces
signaux dont je parle
si oui est-ce que vous adhérez
il y a peut-être parmi vous des
kakistocrates heureux des kakistocrates
assumées des kakistocrates qui ignorent
si ce n'est pas le cas
et bien faut du courage aurez-vous le
courage de dénoncer ces procédés car
vous avez bien compris que si vous
attaquez à la kakistocratie vous vous
attaquez aux gens qui qui ont le pouvoir
et qui n'ont pas envie de le laisser
et puis dernière étape est-ce qu'à votre
niveau vous pouvez faire quelque chose
que l'acteur en vous fasse bouger le
système par exemple recruter des gens
qui sont talentueux dans votre service
alors que ce n'est pas du tout la
pratique dans l'organisation
c'est compliqué de faire bouger les
lignes seul
alors il y a trois pistes pour faire
évoluer les choses trois pistes
intéressantes
pour sortir la kakistocratie la première
c'est de recruter des femmes
[Applaudissements]
alors non pas parce qu'elles sont plus
vertueuses
mais parce qu'elles ont un rapport à la
légitimité et au pouvoir et à la
compétence différents des hommes
statistiquement
je vous donne un exemple très drôle en
2011 une loi copézimmermann
exige la parité dans les conseils
d'administration des entreprises
il y a que des hommes
donc on va chercher des femmes des
femmes puissantes des femmes de
direction des femmes intellectuellement
équipées et elles disent ah oui oui moi
je suis très intéressée mais je ne me
sens pas compétente pour être dans un
conseil d'administration ça s'apprend je
voudrais une formation
donc on fait des formations pour ces
femmes et qui on voit arriver dans ces
formations
ces messieurs qui depuis des années si
j'ai dans les conseils d'administration
sans se poser la question de la
compétence
donc recruter des femmes c'est challenge
l'incompétence l'incompétence
deuxième piste très intéressante et très
paradoxale c'est de valoriser
l'incompétence alors on part de loin
dès l'école maternelle ou de CP on vous
fait valoir que une erreur c'est une
faute qu'il vaut mieux camoufler ses
échecs
qu'être incompétent c'est montrer sa
vulnérabilité et bien si on faisait de
l'incompétence de l'échec de l'erreur
quelque chose d'apprenant
pour avancer
Mandela disait quelques fois on gagne et
quelques fois on apprend et bien se
mettre dans cette situation
d'apprentissage c'est une façon de
lutter contre la kakistocratie
et la troisième piste c'est le name and
shame des Anglo-Saxons c'est-à-dire
pointer du doigt ces pratiques les
dénoncer pour que plus personne n'ait
envie de rejoindre ses organisations et
plutôt envie de les quitter
alors on est devant des situations
complexes et Churchill disait il ne faut
jamais gaspiller une bonne crise
je pense qu'en matière de crise nous
avons été servis depuis 2 ans
il faut faire quelque chose
nous savons maintenant de quelle
management nous avons envie
nous avons envie d'aménagement
bienveillant d'un management éthique
d'un management équitable d'aménagement
qui reconnaît les personnes qui
reconnaît leur compétences qui reconnaît
leur mérite leurs efforts
il faut avancer et
régénérer nos Modalités de management
comme je l'ai dit c'est complexe
ça demande beaucoup de courage
c'est vrai que les kakistocratie de
façon
consubstantielle se reproduisent
mais ce que je vous dis aussi c'est
qu'elles ne sont pas une fatalité
nous pouvons si nous ne voulons vous
pouvez si vous le voulez briser les
chaînes
et ça j'espère vous en avoir donné
l'envie et l'énergie
merci
[Musique]